[Music]
fans tonight we have any special guest
in the building to help us here on the
records and celebrate came one of the
NBA Finals and tonight we're honored to
welcome back some Toronto Raptor greats
who made their mark and Radford's
history books themselves would you
please welcome the former general
manager of each run Raptors and NBA Hall
of Famer Isiah Thomas he's the shortest
player to ever play the NBA he retired
as the Raptor Mugsy boos a power forward
and one of the best rebounders in the
NBA
mr. Rose Oakley he's a junkyard dog
welcome back jyd whoo
sharone youngnam's playing for the
Raptors for 99202 and retiring with
Toronto
please welcome Joe hurry an NBA Hall of
Famer and first round traffic for the
Raptors and 97 team at Tracy McGrady
crowned by the Raptors in 2000 hits
Bobby Morris Petersen he's an 11-time
all-star please welcome back the one and
only Chris
[Music]
and he was part of the Raptors story
from the beginning and some stubborn
shopping for the team let's welcome back
Damon
fans let's make some noise for your
Twitter Raptors alibi